the harry potter movies are packed full
of a lot of stuff and vfx is one of them
there's a lot of
it's the platform nine and three
quarters scene is a good example of
basically sleight of hand coolest water
ball i've ever seen in my life seriously
look how
good that is dude no no
oh so how do you think they did that
shot
thanks to our sponsor vessy stick around
to the end to figure out how you can get
25 bucks
off your pair of vessy's shoes guys
welcome
back to vfx artists react we are finally
doing it the
ultimate harry potter episode guys
actually watched all eight movies
believe it or not every single one so
i'm i'm very excited
to break these effects down with y'all
dude i'm excited too we will do our best
to cover the coolest effects that we can
but
there are eight movies each one filled
with visual effects
we're gonna go over all that stuff it's
gonna be sweet so let's let's just jump
in
shut up shut up oh dude this scene
this scene
[Music]
this is like such a big moment in the
movie too because it's like wait what
she's inflating
it looks so good right yeah it's
incredible
this is no it feels like it's 100
practical i mean you know mine it's like
a wire paint out or something
i mean that's exactly it this entire
scene is practical
dude that's incredible they actually had
like three different
fat suits that she was able to wear and
they actually had a bunch of different
bladders inside of the actual suit that
could inflate
it's an actual physical prosthetic and
none of that is digital like the way it
folds and she moves her head around yeah
such a good little touch that you get
from the practical they actually put a
stunt double in the big suit because
they put her up in the air on wires and
so all the
actual digital effects happening here is
just wire removal i'm just blown away
at the gravity effects that they have it
actually looks like she's bouncing like
a balloon that's full of helium and
to get that wire set up and to be able
to replicate that look
i imagine is very difficult did they
replace the ceiling maybe
is the ceiling cg i'm imagining the
ceiling itself
is not there on set i think it's like a
classic sitcom where you have all the
walls go straight up and you have like
the crown molding
and then just nothing you got rigging
and lights above that because for her to
go
from the dining room to this like a
little patio room
she's probably attached to like four
wires i think so yeah no i think she's
attached to a few wires because notice
how they cut
they never actually show her go entirely
through the doorway they show it through
a series of cuts so yeah i wanted to
bring this up because this is a cool
example of something that was
a cool mesh between you know doing
everything practically but
using visual effects to make it happen
so the platform nine and three quarters
scene is a good example of
basically sleight of hand there's
effects here you know basic rotoscoping
it's actually not that crazy but we have
this transition where harry potter
enters wizard train station land
[Music]
whoa so my first guess is that this was
done in multiple shots
you know this is funny because like
that's how i would do it too but they
don't cut this is the same shot of harry
the whole time
the way they did the shot is pretty cool
so this background here is actually the
background we see
later after he's gone through the pillar
but they've done vfx to replace the cool
old-fashioned steam locomotive with
these new trains so that's basically
just an image in the background here and
if you watch you see how the reflections
don't move on the top
right it's even 2d it doesn't actually
distort yep it's just a picture
it's literally just a picture in that
corner because no one's looking at it
yeah you're looking at harry's face
yep so what happens after the screen
goes dark what's happening there so they
just they straight up just do a lighting
gig they just turn off the lights and
they do a new light where that turns on
here on the side the brick wall behind
him is cg
really that's a full cg brick wall full
cg brick wall okay that's a fake
harry potter shadow right there yeah and
the thing is they have this problem like
okay so how do we reveal the wall like
does it just
fade in like that's kind of lame how do
we reveal the wall it just went with the
tried and true
wipe so as that bill hop walks across it
reveals the wall it's really subtle
okay sure it causes your eye to
completely miss when the wall appears
it's just
there but these are like the
psychological tricks that a good vfx
artist can really implement to make
impactful shots and then he steps around
the corner and they reveal the set
that's actually there but okay no i'm
confused it's a wall that extends
forward it's not a pillar
yeah that's cg on the right yeah the
brick wall i mean you can see the
texture tiling so you can actually see a
repeating pattern going up the side of
the brick wall there yeah that's so
funny
in this day and age that train would be
entirely cg yeah totally they don't have
the capabilities to make the train look
realistic with the steam like that
back in the day like the technology does
not exist so they had the train there
for real and this is a situation where
it's easier to put something over the
train and then reveal it
than it is to have the thing there and
then try to comp in a new big
awesome cool looking train it's like no
make that your real stuff and then
paint it out later for the beginning of
the shot yeah it's always about what is
the easiest or cheapest thing to do
these days it's hard to make a big train
like that for real but it's easy to make
one digitally so it's like if we were to
redo that shot we would have the
beginning of it all be real and then the
end of it be fake
yep
welcome hari to diagonal
alley
so you might be like hey it's harry
potter they have all the money in the
world they built this crazy set they
actually did build a crazy set but the
set ends
like 10 feet into the air well there's
your money harry gringos the wizard bike
so this shot right here it looks real
doesn't it yeah how do you think they
did it i don't know niko how they do
you know how i did it it's a miniature
right
miniature it's a miniature but here's
the challenge they have a moving camera
and they film people for real and they
look up at where this thing is supposed
to be
now these days if you did that shot
you'd film your shot you know you have
your blue screen or something up and
you'd go into the computer and you'd
camera track the shot or match move the
shots yeah basically the computer
analyzes points in the scene
and based on how those points move it
can figure out where the camera was and
where it was moving what it was doing so
they did that of course but here's the
thing they don't now have just a 3d
model they can drop in
what they need to do is take your
miniature get another camera
put it on a computer controlled arm
miniaturize the movement that they did
and then replicate that exact camera
motion
on that computer arm filming the
miniature so they can stick the
miniature shot into this shot and all
the motion lines up
which is such like a clunky and hard way
to go about doing things
because the cameras stay the same size
the sensors stay the same size the
lenses stay the same size and now you're
trying to marry these two shots together
and one of the challenges they face with
the shot that took them a long time to
fix
was lens distortion because it's a wide
angle shot and there's a little bit of
lens distortion in it but the distortion
is different for a miniature that's
filmed up close versus an actual
building that's still far away
yeah i think that's something that is so
cool and i want to try and mess with
i've literally been wanting to get like
some sort of motion control system for
years now
just so we can experiment with bringing
back something like this yeah like that
that to me is
that's how you make a movie look real
little quick trivia vfx moment for you
guys all these candles
floating in the air cg right wrong a
hundred percent real
those are all practical candles it just
makes your job so much easier as a
filmmaker to like
have a magical space to work with yep
gryffindor
[Music]
yay you're in a wizard
okay but looking at this hat so
obviously the entire hat is cg because
it's like a character right
but it's interfacing with a person right
so they have a wireframe hat that the
actors are working with oh really now
the thing is when that
brim falls across the face you see a
shadow fall on their face and this is a
big problem you have when you have cgi
objects casting shadows
is that there should be zero directional
lighting coming from the top
in fact what should be happening is
harry potter in the shadow should be lit
from the bottom because the only light
that'd be reaching his face there would
be light
bouncing off the floor like right here
technically you wouldn't have the
highlight on his glasses because it'd be
reflecting
the bottom of the hat which is in
darkness yep in fact actually
let me grab the sombrero get our
animatronic sorting head all right i got
our sorting hat here
so now as ren puts this on we're gonna
lose all this top lighting here
yeah also keep a look at the specular
highlights on his glasses how they
disappear
look at his nose see how the bottom of
his nose is now brighter than the top of
his nose now remove the hat
now the top of his nose is brighter than
the bottom of his nose so you put that
hat down there's no more light coming
from this direction the only light's
coming from this direction
so his face is now under lit but harry
potter's face with the hat
is not under lit wait but which house am
i in you're in my house now
oh son griffin
it's such a subtle thing no one would
catch this like
no one in the theater would catch this
but it it's a thing it totally is a
thing
but that being said this is an effects
artist trying to compensate for
decisions made on set and i think
they're doing a pretty good job
they're doing a solid job cause i mean
look at the shape of that shadow it
actually deforms around his face
perfectly in his nose it comes up over
his nose it's perfect
everything about this is perfect except
for the fact that an artist had to
somehow go in
and paint out directional lighting on
harry potter but they still did a great
job the compositors on this film are
like world-class compositors
there are so many effects across eight
movies of course we can't talk about all
the effects in this one episode so we
will be doing another harry potter
special but the difference this time is
that we are gonna specifically use your
comment recommendations for that second
episode so leave a comment down below
we'll read them and we'll review them on
camera it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen
[Music]
intriguing isn't it
no no oh
how did they do that they did it god
they missed you had real wizards on set
that probably slid by
a lot of people i don't know it's pretty
in your face you're like wow i just went
through a mirror
concentrate
[Music]
the bow guard is interesting and all
like they do some really cool
transitions
but for me personally the thing that is
most compelling from this whole
scene is just the camera and how they
use it to go through the mirror
sorry about that interesting so we've
been in their imaginations the whole
time and now we're back to reality
that's so cool oh my god however look at
harry
he's flipped the entire scene is flipped
the
ending shot of this entire thing is
reversed his patch is on the wrong side
his scar is on the wrong side
what are they implying are we in a
different dimension now we were in a
different dimension the whole time and
when they started learning defense
against the dark arts they were actually
in the real world just for a moment no i
think
i don't think anyone actually gave that
too much thought they're just like
you're going through it has to be a
mirror image
of what you're seeing because you know
it's a reflection so
how do you think they did that shot i
have an idea well first you get you're
looking at the mirror shot right you
move forward at a set speed figure out a
way to do that whether it's controlled
or you just have a little song playing
in your head you're hitting marks at a
certain speed whatever it is
and you flip your camera or set up your
people for the actual angle that you're
seeing through the mirror and then you
have a little cgi thing in the middle i
just try to match the speed twice and
then blend between them
yeah exactly that's exactly it the
camera's just pushing in on like this
nothing thing there and they're tracking
that shot and rendering in this cabinet
that has you know a mirror front
all they do is they take the footage of
the second film shot
and just put that on a plane behind the
camera and so that the cabinet itself
is reflecting that so that means at some
point
they're transitioning from the
reflection of the real footage to the
real footage
exactly yeah and it's done even more
intensely right here at the end
because notice the mirror moves you know
the whole door is open and it's
reflecting the side of the room there
they actually had to have footage of the
side of that room there built out in 3d
space
and it happens so fast you know it's a
very dynamic shot
it works very well i just thought it was
it's pretty cool touch of filmmaking
that again requires visual effects to
make happen
dude pretty cool that's amazing that's
so good
i think magic is cool but i'm kind of
cited by the fact that no one's done
like
the kind of stuff that you think magic
should be able to do especially if you
play some d and d
yeah magic can be brutal but this is a
children's movie franchise
that can't be brutal but what if someone
could you know make it brutal
yeah what if someone could make it
brutal almost like if
harry potter was rated r what if someone
already did all that in the videos
coming out tomorrow
on the corridor crew channel that's
right
we made rated r harry potter we took
some of our favorite moments and we made
them
violent like really violent like
seriously violent so harry potter rated
r is coming out tomorrow on this channel
if you're not subscribed
and you want to see it consider
subscribing
[Music]
so a major character in these movies is
voldemort
and he doesn't come into the picture
until like the fourth movie one of the
key visuals of voldemort is the fact
that he's got like
no nose he's got like this snake slit
type thing going on
they did most of all this stuff with
makeup you know they painted his face to
be a little
more pale they gave him all like these
veins and stuff over his head and
whatnot but he still has a nose
a lot of the time there are no tracking
markers and some of the close-ups they
do have the tracking markers they would
then
obviously track his head and try to just
recreate that they had a very accurate
photo scan of his entire head both with
and without
the makeup and prosthetic on and then in
compositing try to use as
little of that as possible because some
of the time they only need to just kind
of replace just the nose here other
times they would have to replace
everything from the eyebrows down to the
bottom lip
that's so much work man that's that's
like the not
fun part of vfx yeah they said it was a
very painstaking process but they had to
make sure it was done
as perfectly as possible because it's a
face
even though it's a weird crazy looking
alien face it is still a face and if
they get any of that wrong
it just doesn't look right
[Music]
dude right away that smoke effect's
pretty sweet yeah right off the bat
oh yeah dude
this is a guy with a leaf blower off the
side of the frame
i love that movie like pulls in the
energy and like turns into a fireball oh
yeah dude
it's so sick
dude this part this part right here
coolest water ball i've ever seen in my
life seriously look how
good that is dude oh my god
dude this right here is so cool
he looks so frail when he puts his arms
i know i know i know like i'm actually
just like
okay that's a little less cool now i
agree they look like little chicken
wings
man what a scene there's a lot to unpack
there
let's get started with i don't know the
wand effects like are you talking about
like the the juicy liquid
yeah yeah effects exactly that's a
really easy effect to do in after
effects you just use this plug-in called
trap code particular
i've done it extensively you think you
could pull that off with trapcode i
did pull it off with trapdood i did a
whole short film with it that's awesome
you gave it the liquidy goops
yeah and they land on the ground and
everything so these guys are using
a program called realflow realflow is
like a liquid simulation tool that
allows you to get you know these liquidy
droopy droppy effects here they're
mixing practical and visual effects
they got a bunch of lights blasting the
actors that's like
critical to selling magical effects like
that is like if you have something
that's generating light you can't just
add it into the scene without having
that light you have to actually have it
there
in person well you can add it into the
scene but it's very very
very very very very hard to make it look
good it's just a waste of time it's like
do it on set yeah
and it's kind of like anytime it's
better if you do it for real this is the
fifth movie
in the fourth movie we see this wand
effect happening for the first time
in the graveyard between harry and
voldemort and they actually
used the old cash data from the fourth
movie and put it in
to the scene into the fifth movie and
when we say cash we're not talking about
like benjamin's we're talking about
c-a-c-h-e
it's a memory cache basically so they've
did a fight scene in another film
and they're doing another scene where
it's basically the same angle we're just
two dudes shooting wands at each other
and they're like look we can just use
our same goop simulation we have the
cache it's already done we don't have to
simulate it just drop those polygons
into the new scene call it a day
so for this movie they shot more
practical elements than all the previous
four movies had combined what yeah the
way they get it to look so real
is they film real elements but we're
looking at a snake here
they didn't possibly ignite a snake on
fire how would they do that so the snake
is a 3d model
and there's like flames that are comp
down that are probably some real fire
bits
but the big thing that makes it look
extra good is there something called
fluid simulation happening
i'm not talking about water i'm talking
about gases it's all these tricks that
are up the sleeves of these vfx artists
to try to really sell this stuff and
make it real
so the way they did this it's a mixture
of 2d and 3d
they got a giant like six foot glass
sphere that they shot high pressure
water into they got
elements of the thing dripping they got
a huge dump tank that they
dumped the water out and they filmed all
of this oh man they did it for real
but the top half of this is a real flow
simulation they're mixing this together
in such a beautiful way and
when the ball falls apart that's just
the dump tank footage that's comped in
perfectly too
so cool man what a scene this is such a
great example of combining practical and
digital
the scene would have not nearly been as
good if there wasn't half of it being
done practically in my opinion it'd be
lackluster at best
guys that was a magical episode very
much like our sponsor
vessy dealing out these magical shoes
these shoes truly aren't magical because
they're waterproof they're not water
resistant they're waterproof
it feels like wearing socks too you
might as well be cast in the driest
spell you got
on both your feet you might as well be
levitating above the water because these
shoes are keeping your feet
dry and also guys these shoes they're
sustainably made
if that didn't get you here's the kicker
guys these shoes are made from dimetex
it's a dual knit material dumbledore's
cape was made from dimetex as well
it keeps your feet warm in the winter
and cool in the summer
just like hogwarts guys they're vegan
they're vegan shoes believe it or not
no mandrakes were harmed during the
creation of these shoes
so you you know you wear them without
feeling guilty every step of your
day this is the best part if you click
the link in the description
and use the code corridor crew you guys
will save 25 bucks
off your pair of vessy shoes it's
totally worth it the shoes are awesome
keeping your feet dry and keeping your
green guts accounts nice and high
so click that link guys you guys look
the closest you can get to the hogwarts
experience
it's right here this is the real magic
thank you so much for watching
remember we're gonna do part two very
soon to kind of talk about some more
stuff we didn't even talk about dobby
we need to talk about quidditch yeah
dude quidditch
the janky quidditch match in the first
movie oh i can't wait to just
dig into it oh yeah there's a whole
bunch more that we've already looked
into and we want to tell you all about
it the chair
transformation scene where he's like a
couch and then he turns into the
professor like god
there's so much good stuff